[ Music ]
JEAN-FRANCOIS BILODEAU:
Have you ever pulled
up your security logs knowing
the clues are in there,
somewhere, but the data feels
too big, too noisy, and too slow
to sift through when
time matters most?
In a real incident the
difference between,
"We think it's fine," and, "We
can prove that what happened,"
often comes down to how quickly
you can ask the right question
of your data.
In this session, you'll
learn how to turn that flood
of telemetry into clear answers
using the Kusto Query Language,
or KQL, in Microsoft Sentinel.
Hello, and welcome.
We're glad you could join us.
I'm Jean-Francois Bilodeau, a
Microsoft Technical Trainer.
In this session, we'll
cover creating queries
for Microsoft Sentinel using
the Kusto Query Language,
also known as KQL.
Together we'll build
a strong foundation
of how KQL statements are
structured, how data flows
through a query, and how to
apply the important operators
to your search, filter, shape,
and analyze the result.
You will also see how to combine
data from multiple tables
and how to extract value
from both structured
and unstructured string
field, aka, text field,
skills you'll use constantly
when hunting threats
and investigating incident
in Microsoft Sentinel.
So let's get started
with this session.
Here we set the stage
for the broader mission,
defending against cyberthreat
using Microsoft Security
Operation Platform.
As you work through this
learning path, keep that goal
in mind, helping a security
operation team detect,
investigate, and
respond effectively.
Let's take a look at where
we are in the course.
This is Learning Path 6,
focused on creating queries
for Microsoft Sentinel using the
Kusto Query Language, or KQL.
Here's the roadmap
for this session.
We'll start by constructing
KQL statements
from Microsoft Sentinel,
then move into analyzing
query result using KQL.
Next we'll build multi-table
statement using KQL,
so you can combine dataset when
a single table isn't enough.
And we'll wrap things up by
working with string data,
also known as "text," in KQL
statement, including extracting
and shaping text and
JSON like content.
As we go, expect a lot
of hands-on querying.
The intent is to demonstrate
each KQL example,
often by typing the KQL, rather
than relying on copy and paste,
except for a larger sample.
You'll also notice the learning
flow emphases practice.
That repetition is what
helps KQL become natural
in real investigation.
Now we begin our first module,
Constructing KQL statements
for Microsoft Sentinel.
This is where you'll learn
the core building blocks,
how to write queries that
are readable, repeatable,
and effective when
you're under pressure.
By the end of this module,
you'll be able to
do three things.
First, you will construct KQL
statements using the standard
pattern that Sentinel and log
analytics expect; second,
you'll use KQL to search log
files for a security event
so you can find the signals
in the noise; and third,
you will filter searches based
on meaningful investigation
criteria, like event time,
severity, domain, and any
other relevant field,
so you can narrow quickly from
everything down to this matters.
KQL query are
read-only requests.
You're asking the
system to process data
and return a result, not to
modify the underlying data.
The language is
written as plain text,
and follows a data flow model
that is designed to be easy
to read, write, and automate.
In practice, you'll build
a query that starts
with a dataset, usually a table,
and then you stream that dataset
through a sequence of operators.
It also helps to remember
the schema organization.
KQL works with entities
arranged in a hierarchy similar
to SQL database,
tables and columns.
The most important mental
model, though, is the pipe.
Everything to the left of a
pipe symbol is processed first
and the result then flows to the
right into the next operator.
If you understand that flow,
you can read almost any query
like a story, start here,
refine this, compute that,
and then return the final
shape of the result.
During demonstration,
you'll typically begin
by accessing a Log
Analytics demo environment
and working directly
in the query window.
And if you want additional
support as you practice,
Microsoft provides a KQL
quick reference and a set
of query best practices
in the Azure Data
Explorer documentation.
Let's start with
the simplest way
to query, referencing a table.
In Sentinel you'll
commonly work with tables
like security events,
security alerts.
Most of what you write will be
a tabular expression, columns
and rows, statements,
meaning the input is a table
and the output is also a table.
When you chain operators
together using pipes,
passing the tabular result
from one step to the next,
at the most basic level
you could run a query
by entering only the table name,
but that approach is
usually inefficient,
because you'll pull back far
more data than you need.
The real power comes
from immediately shaping
and filtering what you retrieve.
When you need to quickly
hunt for a term across data,
the search operator is
a fast way to begin.
For example, you might
use something as simple
as "Search 'New'" to find
records containing that word.
You can also sculpt the
search to a specific table
like searching within "Security
Event" and any table that starts
with "App" by using
the pattern such as
"Search Event, App," "New".
This is especially useful
early in an investigation
where you're still figuring
out where the relevant
evidence might live.
Most investigations rely heavily
on the "Where" operator.
Because filtering is how you
get from broad telemetry
down to events that matter.
A common first filter
is "Time," for example,
starting with "Security Event"
and then narrowing to "Event,"
where time generated is
within the last hour using
"Time generated greater than
ago 1h," as in one hour.
From there, you can combine
condition into a single step,
such as filtering the last hour
and also matching an event ID
like, "Event ID equal, equal,
double quote, 4624,"
for a logon event.
You can also express the same
logic as multiple "where" steps,
which can be easier to read.
First filter by time,
then by event ID,
then maybe by account
type, for example,
using the case insensitive
equality operators,
the equal tail, with
a value like "User".
And when you want to
match several event IDs,
you can use "In," such as
filtering, "Where event ID in,"
and then specify the event ID,
4624, 4625, as an example,
put them in bracket for
successful and failed login.
Using the LET statement.
As your query grows,
you'll want them
to be easier to
read and maintain.
And that's where the LET
statement comes into play.
With LET, you can declare
variables and reuse them.
For example, you might design,
"Time offset equals --
" what age, what hour, and,
"Discard Event ID equals 4688,"
then filter "Security Event"
to a specific window,
events between time ago, time
offset times two, so two hours,
and ago time offset also
excludes a noisy event ID
by checking that this event
ID, exclamation mark,
equal discarded event ID,
so not equal event --
discarded event ID.
You can also use LET to
define a reusable dataset.
For example, you could
build a table called
"Low Activity Accounts" by
summarizing count by "Account",
and then keeping only accounts
with fewer than 1,000 events.
After that, you can reference
the low-activity account
like any other table and further
filter, such as finding account
where the name contains
the string "SQL".
This pattern helps you
declare and reuse variables,
and also declare
dynamic table or lists
that can simplify
complex hunting logic.
Next let's create new
fields on the fly
with the "Extend" operator.
"Extend" adds calculated
column to your result,
which is incredibly useful when
you need to derive a value
that doesn't exist
directly in the data.
For example is starting
with security events,
filtering on the last hour and
ensuring both process name
and "Process aren't empty."
From there you can compute a
new column called "StartDir,"
by using the
"Substring" function
and "String Size" function
to strip the process name
down to just the starting
directory portion.
Another powerful pattern
is normalizing value
into a sortable order.
For example, using
security alert
over the last seven days you
can extend a new column called
"Severity Order" using the
"Case" function, mapping high
to three, medium to two, low to
one, and informational to zero,
and using minus
one as a default,
for example, for missing values.
This makes it much
easier to sort, group,
or threshold alert consistently
in later steps in the demo.
Once you filter and enrich
your dataset, you often need
to sort it to spot patterns.
The "Order By" operator
does exactly that.
Building on the previous example
where we computed "StartDir,"
you can order the result with
"StartDir Descending", D-E-S-C,
and then "Process
Ascending," A-S-C.
Sorting like this can quickly
reveal unusual directories,
rare processes, or
anything that stands
out once the noise
has been reduced.
Another essential set of
tools is the "Project" family
of operator, which controls
the shape of your output.
With "Project," you choose
which column is included
in the output, and
you can rename, drop,
or answer
newly-computed columns.
If you want to exclude
a certain column,
you can use "Project Away".
If you want to keep
only a specific column,
use "Project Keep".
To rename fields cleanly,
use "Project Rename".
And if you want to just reorder
the columns in the output,
use "Project Reorder".
For example, you might start
a security event and simply
"Project Computer" and
"Account" to focus your view.
Or you can take a longer
query filtering by time,
ensuring process fields are
present, extending "StartDir",
sorting the result,
and then finish
by removing a
verbose column like
"Process Name" using
"Project Away".
This is a great habit for making
your result easier to read
and easier to share
with your teammate.
With the fundamentals in place,
let's move into analyzing
query results with KQL.
This is where KQL becomes more
than "Find Event," it's a way
to summarize what's happening
and communicate it clearly.
After completing this
module, you'll be able
to summarize data
using KQL statement
and render visualization
using KQL statement.
These capabilities help you
answer high-level questions
like, "How often is this
happening, who is most impacted,
and is the situation
getting better
or is it getting
worse over time?"
The "Summarize" operator is
the heart of analysis in KQL.
It groups records and
calculate aggregates
so you can understand
patterns at scale.
Common functions include "tell,"
"count if" to count records,
"dcount" and "dcount if" to
estimate distinct value.
We've got "average" and
"average if" for average,
"max" and "max if" for maximums,
"sum" and "sum if"
for a total value.
For a quick example, you
could take security events
from the last hour and
summarize a number
of distinct IP addresses using
"Summarize Distinct IP".
In a more investigation-focused
scenario,
you might define a timeframe,
like 30 days, and a threshold
that queries sign-in logs
for sign-in attempts
where the result description
contains invalid password.
From there, you can summarize
the distinct number
of applications being
targeted by counting
"Distinct App
Display Name" value
or "User Principal Name"
and "IP Addresses".
And finally, filter to a case
where the application count
meets or exceeds your threshold.
This kind of query helps
highlight suspicious patterns
such as password spray
activity across many apps.
Beyond counting and
distinct values,
"Summarize" can help you filter
by keeping only the most
relevant record in each group.
Two key functions are
"Arg Max," "Arg Min."
For example, if you
filter a security event
to a specific host like
"SQL10.na.contosohotels.com,"
you can use "summarize
arg_max(TimeGenerated,*)
by Computer" to keep the most
recent records by computers;
or you can use
"arg_min(TimeGenerated,*)
by Computer" to keep only
the earliest record.
Sometimes the goal isn't
just to calculate a number,
it's to prepare unstructured
output so you can reuse or pivot
on to function to help our
"make_list" and "make_set".
For example, you might
query "Security Event"
for the last hour, filter
to successful logon with
"Event ID equals 4624," and then
summarize "Make List Account
by Computer," to create a list
of accounts seen on each host.
If you want unique values only,
you can use
"Make_set(Account)" instead.
Once your data is
summarized, you can turn it
into visual using the
"Render" operator.
Common visualization includes
area chart, pie chart,
column chart, scatter
chart, time chart.
For example, you could
take the security events
over the last hour,
summarize count by account,
and then render a
bar chart to see
which account appears
more frequently.
Or you can summarize count
over time using a bin,
such as "bin(TimeGenerated,
1m)," meaning one minute,
and then render a time chart
to visualize activity
trend minute by minute.
Now, let's move beyond
single-table query and focus
on building multi-table
statements using KQL.
In a real Sentinel
investigation,
the story is often spread
across multiple data sources.
So you need to merge
and correlate table
to see the full picture.
After completing this
module, you'll be able
to create query using
unions to merge results
from multiple tables and you'll
be able to merge two tables
with the "Join" operator.
These two techniques,
using "Union"
and "Join" are foundational
for correlating activities
across identity logs and
point events, alerts,
and application telemetry.
The "Union" operator
lets you combine rows
from multiple tables into a
single unified result set.
As a simple example is
"SecurityEvent / union
SigninLogs," which pulls events
from both sources
into one stream
so you can continue the process.
Once you've unioned
tables, you can summarize
across the combined
dataset, for instance,
running "Summarize Count," and
then projecting that count
into a clean output column.
You can also union in
a more advanced way,
like unioning a base table
with the summarized output
of another query in parentheses.
For example, unioning
"Security Event"
with a summarized count
from sign-in log.
Another common technique
is using wild card such as
"Union App*" and then
summarizing count by type
to understand how many
records are coming
in from each matching table.
While union stacks result,
"Join" correlates them.
The "Join" operator combines
records from two datasets based
on a matching key,
such as account name
and a device name, a
session identifier.
In this example, we started
with "Security Event" filtered
to log-on event, for example,
where Event ID is 4624,
then summarized a
log-on count by account
and project log-on
count and account.
Next we join, using
"Kind equals inner,"
which a second dataset
built from log-off event,
where Event ID equals 4634,
summarizing a log-off count
by account and
projecting the same key.
Joining one account
gives a combined view
where you can compare log-ons
and log-off side by side.
When you join table, a specific
join kind, sometimes called
"Join flavor" determines
which record are kept
on the left side, the right
side, or both, it's essential
to understand the
impact of that choice.
With some join kinds you'll keep
only the matches with the other,
you'll preserve unmatched
record from one side.
As you build correlated query
for investigation, always pause
and confirm what should
happen to records
that don't have a match.
That's one decision that can
completely change the conclusion
you draw from the data.
Next, we'll focus on
working with string data,
also known as text, plain
text, using KQL statements.
Security data often contains
key information embedded inside
text, things like command line,
account, strings, JSON blob,
and even event message.
So being able to extract
and transform text
is a major advantage
in hunting an incident response.
After completing this module,
you'll be able to extract data
from unstructured
field, extract data
from structured string data,
and create functions using KQL.
These skills help
you turn nasty text
into a clean field you can
filter, summarize, and join,
just like any other columns.
To pull value out of
unstructured text,
KQL provides the
"Extract" function,
which uses regular expression.
A simple illustration
is printing the result
of the example we have onscreen
and confirming it returns 45.6.
That pattern defines a
regex, regular expression.
Choose a capture
group, the brackets,
and apply it to a string.
Scale directly into
real security data.
For example, you might
query security event
for a privileged activity
event, like Event ID 4672,
and focus on a record where
"Account Type" equals "User".
From there you can create
a normalized account field
by extending a new column, such
as "Account Name," and using the
"Extract" function
with a regex designed
to pull just the
username portion
from a different account
format, converting the input
to lowercase for consistency.
Once the account
name is extracted,
you can summarize a login
count by account name,
exclude empty result, and
then filter to account
with fewer than,
let's say, 10 logins,
an approach that can help
highlight rare privilege login
worth investigating.
Another approach for
unstructured string is the
"Parse" function, which is great
when the text follows
a consistent pattern.
In this example, we create
a small data table called
"Traces," with a column
named, "Event Text,"
containing a structured
message like, "Event:
NotifySliceRelease," as we
see onscreen over here.
When we parse event text,
mapping part of the string into
"Name" field like, "Resource
name," "Total slice,"
as a long slice number, as a
long, which is a 64-bit value,
and "Time Stand," such as log
time, release time as a date,
and previous log time as
a date, after parsing,
we project those
extracted fields
so the output becomes a
clean table you can analyze.
Now let's take a look at
structured string data,
especially dynamic
fields and JSON.
In sign-in logs, some properties
are already available
as dynamic object.
So you can extend
fields directly.
For example, you can extend
a new column OS from the
"Device Detail" columns,
"DeviceDetail.operatingSystem"
to quickly analyze sign-in
by operating system.
When JSON in stored as a
string, you can convert it
into a dynamic object
using "parse_json."
For instance, you might extend
the "AuthDetail" by parsing the
"Authentication Detail"
field, then extracting value
from the first elements,
like "AuthMethod" from
"AuthDetail[0]," authentication
method, and "AuthResult"
from a nested field, such as
"AuthDetails[0]," the first one,
and then the field name
"Authentication Step
Result Detail".
Finally, you can project
"AuthMethod," "AuthResult,"
and default "AuthDetailObject"
to validate your parsing.
In some scenarios, you'll
want to enrich your query
with external data, like a
watchlist of user ID hashes
or known indicators
stored outside Sentinel.
KQL supports this with the
external data capability.
For example, you might query
a user table and filter
where user ID is
in a list returned
by your external
data user ID string.
Pulling value from a text file
holds it an Azure Blog Storage.
In practice, access to that blob
typically requires a secret
token, such as a SaaS
token, so always plan
for secure access control when
integrating external sources.
To make your KQL reusable, you
can save queries as functions,
especially useful for parsers
and common
investigation pattern.
For example, you might start
from, "Security event filtered
by event ID equals 4672 and
account type equals user,"
and then save the query as a
function name privileged login.
After it's saved, you can
invoke it by simply calling
"PrivLogins," just like you
would reference a table.
Now, it's time to bring
everything together
in a focused demonstration.
Here we'll create and run KQL
query in Microsoft Sentinel,
applying the patterns
we've seen so far.
In this demo, let's take a look
at Log Analytics workspace,
how to query with KQL through
our defender workspace.
First thing I'll do here is
crack open Microsoft Sentinel,
open our workspace, and under
"Log," enter the query hub.
So let's select "Sentinel,"
let's go into "Logs."
Let's close the query hub.
This is useful to get started,
but we're going to
get started raw.
This brings us to the query
history in "Simple Mode."
Let's switch to "KQL Mode".
KQL mode will allow us
to write raw KQL query,
great for learning,
great for understanding.
It's also, in my opinion, the
fastest way to write query.
On the left over here,
we can select tables
we'd like to query.
But in our case, I'll just
start typing the name
of the table I want to query.
Let's go with "Security Events".
This is about the simplest
query you can create.
Type in the name of a table,
hit the "Run" button, boom,
here's a list of
results for you.
We're seeing all of the rows in
our Security Events CL table.
Actually, we're not
seeing all the rows
because there are
filters at the top.
We can see we're only showing
the first 1,000 results
and the last 24 hours as well.
If necessary, we can change the
time range or choose the number
of results that show up.
We can do that either
through the toolbar
or we can do it directly
inside the query interface,
which we'll see later on.
Another way that we can query --
start a query in KQL
is by doing a search.
Let me give you an example
over here search, "Computer."
What this does over here is it
will take a look at every table
and every entry,
and pull up results
that have the word,
"Computer" in them.
Here we go.
Notice the dollar sign table
in the columns over here.
That tells me which table
see the results come from.
Some come from the
office activity,
others from security event.
We can see why those rows were
included, they have the word,
"Computer" in them
under the account.
When it comes to the one
for office activity,
would be somewhere
else in the entry.
Well, let's take a look at
a variant on the search.
We're going to say now search in
"Security Event" and any table
that begins with "App," App*,
and we're going to look
for the word, "New" this time.
Let's run the query, and
here are our results.
Again, same principle,
because it's a search,
it's going to break up
a variety of table,
look in all tables
that we've selected.
We can see which table
the results we're seeing
over here come from using the
dollar sign table column.
Now, let's start
adding some filter.
We know that we can filter using
time range at the top over here.
But let's filter right in the
core, very useful especially
if you're going to save
queries and reuse them.
So we're going to search
query "Security Event,"
but now we're going
to add a predicate
where time generated
greater than "ago 7 days."
So let's go back one week,
so from now to one week ago.
Notice because we are now
adding a predicate based
on time generated, time range
now says, "Set in query."
Here are the results.
So now we are seeing the
last seven days of activity
in "SecurityEvent_CL".
We can filter further.
For example, in the table, we
have an "Event ID" column.
Let's filter by that one.
I'll add an "and clause"
over here and "Event ID,"
and we're going to put in two
equals and let's go with 4624.
Run event, and now we're looking
at the last seven days of events
and all the event
IDs that are 4624.
To make it easier to read,
let me put that on
two separate rows.
So we'll have one row
to filter the duration,
another row to
filter by event ID.
Makes it a little
bit easier to read.
We're going to add another
word clause over here,
where we're going to search
by account, by account type.
And let me use a different
operator this time.
I'll use the equal tail
and the word, "User."
The equal tail does a
case insensitive search.
Notice over here how the
word, "User" has a capital U,
but in the query, I wrote
it with a lowercase U.
So that's a good
operator to know.
It's an operator you'll see very
often in sample KQL queries.
Another useful operator
I'd like to introduce you
to is the "In" operator.
What if I'd like to look
at multiple event IDs,
not just 4624, but
say, 2645 as well?
Let me use the "In"
operator where Event ID
in an inside bracket, let me
put in all the values I'd
like to use, 4624, 4625.
There we go, now we've
got both event IDs coming
up in the result.
We could also negate the
condition by saying,
"Where Event ID not in," and
provide a list of events.
Now, as our queries get
more sophisticated,
we'll want to make it easier
for us to make changes
to values we provide in here.
And I'd like to
explore with you how
to use variables
in your queries.
Here's a quick example for you.
Let me drop that in here.
And notice in this query we're
adding two LET statements,
"Let -- time offset
equals 10 minutes,
let discarded Event
ID equal 4688."
And following that,
we are querying our
security event CL table.
But what's different now is
where we have our
condition like,
"Where time generated greater
than ago time offset,"
time offset is our variable
we've defined as a name
that we've chosen to
represent 10 minutes.
There it is.
So we don't have to repeat it,
we are creating a
one-minute window at 10
and 11 minutes here, so we don't
have to repeat 10 minutes.
And furthermore, if
we want to change it,
there's only one place where we
need to go now, the variable.
Let's run the query and see
that while the same will apply
to discarded event IDs,
"Discarded event ID" is now
at the top, making
it easy to change.
There we go, here is the result
of our query, time-generated.
We're looking at
just one minute,
10 minutes ago, 11 minutes ago.
And the event ID we should see
every event ID except 4688.
We're using the exclamation mark
equal over here, not equal,
so give me everything
except 4688.
So this gives us a convenient
way to improve the readability
of our query, make it
easier to change our query,
avoid duplication when
we modify the query
when we write the query.
Let's continue our
exploration of KQL.
Now let's take a look at how
to summarize an aggregate
result in our query.
Instead of seeing
individual rows,
I'd like to see
aggregates of those rows.
So we're going to start with our
same table, "Security Event".
We're going to clamp it to seven
days a week and Event ID 4688.
But notice the next line
now, we're adding the
"Summarize" operation,
"Summarize count by computer."
So what I'd like to
know over here is
in our security event how many
times has a computer shown
up in here?
Let's run the query.
There's our result.
We could see over here which
for our computers show
up more often, less often,
based on the count by computer
that we have over here.
We can see the
VictimPCContosoAzure has a lot
of activity, giving us a sense
that hey, maybe we'll want
to take a look at this machine.
Notice as well how
"count" is spelled
with an underscore over here.
We can change the
name to "column".
For example, I'll use "CNT".
I cannot use the word, "Count,"
because that's a built-in word.
But let me say, "CNT equals
count by account type,"
and notice that the count column
is now simply known as "CNT,"
or any other name I
would've chosen to select.
There is the account
type, the computer,
and the count of events.
So now we're looking at the
account type, the computer,
and how many times does
that combination come
up in the last seven days,
so "user@victimPC"
shows up 10 times.
Here's a variant for you.
Let's explore a new
query with sign-in logs
where time generated is one
week ago, but now we're going
to summarize not by count but
by dcount, distinct count.
I want to know how many distinct
IP addresses do I have,
and in this case,
in my sign-in logs,
I can see that only one
IP address is used.
That's what the one
represents over here.
If I saw two, that would mean
there are two different IP
addresses that shows
up in that log.
Let's continue to refine this.
Here's a slightly more
sophisticated query over here.
We're still going to use dcount,
and we're going to use variables
at the top going back,
in this case, 30 days.
We're going to look for
a result description,
the result description
column that has the text,
"User account is disabled,"
and we're in the column.
And now we're going to summarize
using dcount over here.
We're going to name the column
"Application count equals dcount
at display name," so
let's display the number
of times a specific
application name shows up,
and we're also going to group
that by user principal
name and by an IP address.
And then we're going to add
a filter to the result.
What we care about is any
application count whose name
shows up one or more times.
And there we go, in this
case, there is only one.
We can see that John with their
IP address has one application
showing up in here.
John's entry with that specific
address may actually show
up multiple times in the logs.
But because we're using dcount,
it shows us that this specific
combination exists only once,
shows up only once in our log.
Last example I'd like
to give you over here.
Let's talk about "make_list"
and "make_sense".
That may seem
intimidating at first,
but I highly recommend
play around with them,
make sure you're
familiar with them.
Here's an example,
"SecurityEvent_CL".
Again, we're going to
go back seven days.
We're going to look
at Event ID 4624,
but now summarized
by "make_list".
So we're going to
create a little table,
a sub-table over here,
"Make_list(Account_s)
by computer."
So we could see over here a
list of computers and beside
that we have a list
of all accounts
that were found
on that computer.
We can expand those
list accounts to see
which accounts are
used by this computer.
So this is a table
within a table.
We're creating a
list of accounts.
Duplicate accounts will show up
multiple times in the table.
Let's expand it.
And notice how we can see
the same account more
than once in the list.
Let's crack that open again,
and notice
"CONTOSOAZURE/AATPService"
shows up a couple of times.
That's "make_list".
"Make_list" does not
remove duplicate,
it shows us all
individual value.
But what if I don't care
about the duplicate,
I just want to know if
that account is present
on that system, I want
to get rid of duplicate.
Well, let's make one quick
change to our query.
Let's use "make_set"
instead of "make_list".
Same thing, but the difference
now is all duplicates will
be removed.
Let's crack open our Victim PC.
Let's take a look
at the account.
And notice now how
"CONTOSOAZURE/AATPService" shows
up only once, even
though we know
that it's there multiple
times in the table.
So "make_list" shows, me
all the individual values,
"make_set" shows me
only distinct values.
For our last set of KQL demo,
let's get into something
a little bit fun.
Let's get into visual.
We'll start with our
security events.
We've seen that a
couple of times.
We're going to filter
by the last seven days.
There is a result,
nothing really new.
But what I'd like to do next
is let's summarize count
by account, so let's see
which accounts were used
in the last seven days.
Here is the result.
But what I'm seeing over here
is the name of an account
and the number of
times they're used.
I'm going to change the
sort over here order
by account going descending,
the account that has the most
activity down to the one
that has the least activity.
Administrator is at the top,
which is always a
bit concerning.
But what I'd like to do over
here is to make it easier for me
to read and evaluate, understand
what's happening over here,
especially in terms of ratio.
Let's generate a visual.
Let's render a bar chart.
Let me add over here at the
end, "Render bar chart."
And there we go, KQL now
generates a bar chart for us,
much nicer visual, allowing
you to get a good sense
as to really how much more
the administrator account is
being used.
And if I'd like to look at
it more from a ratio side,
how about we render
a pie chart instead?
And there we go,
here's our pie chart.
Again, administrator
represents, what,
42.97% of all account activity.
Not too surprising, but
maybe a bit concerning.
Either there's privilege, abuse,
or maybe something
else is happening.
But one way or another,
we've seen over here how
to generate visual using KQL.
Let's recap what
you've accomplished
in this learning path.
You have learned how to
construct KQL statement
from Microsoft Sentinel,
building queries
that follows the dataflow model.
You practiced key KQL operators,
like "Summarize," "Render,"
"Union," "Join," and "Extend"
to filter, shape, analyze,
and visualize your result.
You also learned how to
extract data from unstructured
and structured text fields,
which is critical for working
with real-world
security telemetry.
And finally, you saw how to
create functions and "Parser,"
using KQL so your best
queries can be reused.
As we close out, take a moment
to reflect on the key outcome.
You now have practical KQL
skill you can apply immediately
in Microsoft Sentinel.
Whether you're hunting,
triaging alerts,
or investigating an incident,
the more you practice writing
queries and reading the pipeline
from left to right, the
faster you'll be able to move
from raw logs with
confident solution.
This concludes our session.
There are many more ways to
continue your learning journey.
We encourage you to watch other
videos in Discourse or search
out your next favorite topic on
Microsoft Learn at aka.ms/learn.